قصاص واكثر كان القصد في البدء الانتقام
لضحايا تفجير اسطنبول الاخير لكنه
الواسعه على مواقع لفصائل كرديه المسلحه
في شمال سوريا والعراق قد تتسع رقعتها
بالتصريح والتلميح معا تنبئك انقره بان
العمليه البريه قادمه لا محاله
اعتبارا من هذه اللحظه نعلن ان لدينا
معيارا واحدا وهدفا واحدا وهو تحقيق امني
مواطنين ودولتنا انه حق شرعي لنا ان نذهب
للنقطه والمنطقه التي يبدا امننا منها
وعلى الدول التي جاءت من مسافه الاف
الكيلومترات لتحقيق امنها باستخدام القوه
المفرطه ان تتفهم حقا الشرعيه هذا هناك خط
رسمناه في مناطق داخل العراق وسوريا
لتحقيق امن مواطنينها واذا تطلب الامر سحب
هذا الخط وتغيير مكانه اكثر فاكثر فاننا
مستعدون لذلك
لا تخفي تركيا تدمرها من دعم دول لما
تعتبره هي منظمات الارهابيه تشير القرى
بذلك الى حزب العمال الكردستاني ووحدات
حمايه الشعب الفلسطيني الابرز فيما تعرف
بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
في ما يخص رؤوس فانه في نظر الاتراك غير
ملتزمين بالمساعده في تطهير المنطقه من
التهديد الارهابي وفقا للاتفاق سوتشي قد
لا يفهم الكريملين الالتزامات بالطريقه
نفسها غير انه يبدي تفهما لهاجز انقره
التي يصفها بالمشروعه بشان ضمان امنها
وتدعوا الرئاسه الروسيه هنا الاطراف كافه
الى ضبط النفس والابتعاد عن الخطوات
المزعزيعه للاستقرار في جميع انحاء سوريا
ولين الامريكيين هناك ايضا فاين الاتراك
حلفائهم في اليوتيوب يدعو لهم الى وقف
دعمهم لمقاتلين اكراد سوريين
واشنطن التي تقود التحالف الدولي الداعم
الرئيسيه لما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه في قتالها ضد تنظيم الدوله
ترفض اي عمل عسكري في سوريا او العراق
شركائها ايضا لعدم التصعيد
في الشمال السوري قالوا ان مسيره تركيه
استهدفت قاعده المشتركه مع قوات التحالف
الدولي بقياده الولايات المتحده لكن
القياده الوسطى للجيش الامريكي
وقوعها غارات على مواقع تستضيف قواتها
قالت ان الوحدات الامريكيه كانت في مناى
من الخطر